BRADY HARAN: OK, everyone.
Prepare yourselves for two of
the most extraordinary dice
rolls you have ever seen
on Numberphile.
But before that, it's time for
some more one-roll Yahtzees
from Numberphile viewers.
First of all, there's this
one from Justin and Ryan.
[BOTH HOLLER]
BRADY HARAN: They get massive
bonus points for the I love
Numberphile body decoration.
But the question I have is did
the other guy, the one who
didn't roll the Yahtzee, also
have I love Numberphile on his
chest, just in case he was the
one that got it first?
RYAN: Boom.
JUSTIN: 2,363.
RYAN: All 4's, [BLEEP].
Woo-hoo!
LUKE: We're gonna try
to roll a Yahtzee.
VICTORIA: Yeah.
For you, Brady.
We're going to roll
you a Yahtzee.
We're going to get this
on the first shot.
We promise.
OK.
Attempt number one.
Oh, shoot!
LUKE: Well, it wasn't Yahtzee.
VICTORIA: OK, it was a 1.
LUKE: Ah!
You got four 1's and
then a 3 then.
VICTORIA: On the very first
try, I got four--
actually, here.
Let's do four of a kind.
LUKE: That's too complicated.
VICTORIA: No, no.
I want to see how many times
we get four of a kind.
LUKE: Look, we're being
so organized.
BRADY HARAN: Now here
are some more.
Just a reminder, each person
has a 1 in 1,296 chance of
rolling a Yahtzee.
ANDREW: Dad!
Look at these!
BRADY HARAN: This one comes from
our friends in Holland.
MARTIJN: Yes.
Oh, yeah.
BRADY HARAN: And OK, here's a
quick little moment for all
the people that used software
or computers and didn't
actually roll real dice.
Not exactly the spirit of
what we're doing, but
you get geek points.
Brett here includes some lovely
graphs with his video.
BRETT: Yes!
BRADY HARAN: Only 55
rolls for this one.
Sometimes when people roll a
Yahtzee, they don't quite
realize they've done
it-- like this.
PERRY: 81 rolls.
Holy cow!
BRADY HARAN: And this.
SETH: Oh, shoot!
This video came from Iceland.
HAUKER: [CLAPS LOUDLY]
RUSSELL: Yessss!
BRADY HARAN: This Popsicle
stick counting system
definitely caught my eye.
JORGE: So I know the odds for
rolling a one roll Yahtzee are
about one in 1,296.
I only have 1,000
Popsicle sticks.
Oh my God.
BRADY HARAN: And how's this
for cool as a cucumber.
JAMES: There we go.
Five 2's.
BRADY HARAN: Compared
to this somewhat
more animated reaction.
TEHCUBEDUDE: Oh, oh, [BLEEP].
We got it.
TEHCUBEDUDE'S FRIEND:
Yeah, [BLEEP]
[BLEEP]
[BLEEP]!
yeah.
[DOG BARKING]
TEHCUBEDUDE: Aaaahhhh!
TEHCUBEDUDE'S FRIEND: Yeah.
Yeah!
Got a Yahtzee!
TEHCUBEDUDE: Now I don't
know what to do.
TEHCUBEDUDE'S FRIEND:
We got a Yahtzee.
TEHCUBEDUDE: You're
full of [BLEEP].
That did not happen.
TEHCUBEDUDE'S FRIEND:
Yes it did.
TEHCUBEDUDE: Holy [BLEEP].
TEHCUBEDUDE: I got a Yahtzee.
That was 592.
592 rolls.
I don't know if I counted--
592 or 593 rolls.
BRADY HARAN: Now not everyone
who's tried has been
successful, but you can
still send in the
videos, like this one.
VICTORIA: We have a kind
of lot though.
[GASP]
Yahtzee!
Oh my God!
(IN SLOW MOTION) We have
a kind of lot though.
[GASP]
Yahtzee!
Oh my God!
LUKE: We got it.
VICTORIA: That was so quick!
I was expecting this to
take like two hours.
It only took like, OK--
5, 10, 15, 20, 25,
30, 36 tries.
And we only had two
four-of-a-kinds before that.
But only 36 tries.
It took us, like, four minutes
and should have
taken, like, two hours.
So we are freaking lucky.
Nice.
BRADY HARAN: Now poor old Lukas,
he missed the moment he
rolled his Yahtzee.
I think his camera stopped
recording.
But don't worry, Lukas.
We believe you.
LUKAS: All right.
I rolled a 5 Yahtzee, but my
camera stopped recording.
LUKAS' FRIEND: He did
it 362 times.
LUKAS: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
362 times.
LUKAS' FRIEND: He's going
to try again.
LUKAS: Yep, I'm going
to do this again.
How much time?
How much time has it been?
LUKAS' FRIEND: Mmm.
LUKAS: How much time?
Nine.
LUKAS: Ha-ha!
NICK: [GASP]
I did it.
MIKE: [GASP]
BRADY HARAN: OK.
Now for those two amazing rolls
I was telling you about.
This first one comes
from James.
Now he upped the ante by not
using a six-sided dice but
using five 10-sided dice.
Now you'll hear his wife asking
something about the
washing machine.
But James, he's on the
brink of greatness.
LAURA: [INAUDIBLE]?
JAMES: Yeah.
LAURA: Can you check to see
if the washer's ready?
JAMES: Yeah, babe.
3,440.
Oh my God!
Laura!
It just happened!
On 3,440!
7, 7, 7, 7, 7.
Holy [BLEEP]!
BRADY HARAN: And even the cat
now gets in on the action.
JAMES: My quest is done.
[CAT MEOWS]
JAMES: Exactly, cat!
JAMES: Yeah!
And yeah.
3,440.
Magic number.
BRADY HARAN: And finally, well,
I think this is the most
amazing roll of all, and it
comes from Seth who was
featured earlier in this video
rolling a Yahtzee.
And I think this is so amazing
I'm going to play it twice.
SETH: Are you kidding me?
Are you kidding me?
BRADY HARAN: Now if you want
to watch some of the other
viewer Yahtzees on the previous
videos, I'll put the
links below the video
and on the screen.
You can also see me
rolling a Yahtzee.
if you want to roll one
yourself, send me the video.
You can upload it to YouTube
or send me the file.
Email address.
And if you've watched all the
Numberphile videos so far, why
not check out 60 Symbols?
It's my physics channel.
I think you'll like
those films, too.
VICTORIA: So we just rolled a
Yahtzee a few minutes ago, and
we decided that we're going to
try to roll it one more time
and see if we can do two
in a row, because--
how epic would that be?
So let's try.
OK.
So this is lucky two-in-a-row
Yahtzee.
Come on, universe!
LUKE: Huaaahhh.
VICTORIA: Noooooo.
LUKE: Awwwwwwwww.